Speaker 1: There are some reports getting
significant traction that the Department of
Justice is deliberately waiting until after
the midterm election to indict Donald Trump
in order to not be seen as making this
political in order to affect the midterms. Now,
a lot of common sense applied to the circumstances
suggests that it's not likely Trump would be
indicted before the midterms anyway. And I'll
tell you why in a moment. A couple of different
reports here. DOJ likely to wait past the
midterms to reveal any Trump charges. That's from
Bloomberg's Chris Strohm. Federal prosecutors are
likely to wait until after the November election
to announce any charges against Trump if they
determine that he broke laws. Business Insider
Reporting. If prosecutors decide to indict Trump,
they'll wait until after the November midterms
based on a report. The move would be
in accordance with longstanding policy
that bars prosecutors from taking overt steps that
could affect the outcome of an election. Attorney
General Merrick Garland also recently introduced
new restrictions to, quote, maintain public
trust in the DOJ. So there's a couple of different
things that I think are important to mention here.
First of all, Donald Trump isn't on any ballot,
so it's a particular layer removed to if what is
happening here is the DOJ is saying we're going to
bring charges, but not until after the election.
Trump is not actually on any ballot, so it would
be better to just do the job that you're trying
to do. Stop going so out of your way. Not to
be political, because at the end of the day,
when you're investigating current or former
elected officials, you're not going to avoid
allegations that it is political in some sense.
Now, if Donald Trump were on the ballot, if Donald
Trump were running for something in November
and two weeks before he is charged with a crime,
although it still could be completely correct and
apolitical. We've gotten all the evidence. We've
gotten all the as Sean HANNITY calls it, the I's
crossed and the T's dotted, and we're ready to go,
if that's the timing, to deliberately wait
until after the election. That actually seems
more politically motivated than just charging
when you're ready to charge. But that's not the
case here because Trump's not even on the ballot.
So if this were the calculation that were being
made by the DOJ, it is a very indirect thing where
it's well, even though Trump's not on the ballot,
there are members of his party on the ballot
and people that he has endorsed on the ballot.
So let's wait. I would be completely
against that. But I actually think that
this entire narrative may not be accurate. And the
reason I say that is. It does take a while to put
together charges and according to people familiar
with what's going on. Eight and a half weeks for
charges. They just got a huge chunk of documents.
It's now September, in August, weeks ago.
It is often the case that it takes months after
search warrants are served to finalize. What are
all the charges. Now, without a doubt, when the
FBI decides we're going into the home of a former
president, which they don't often decide, arguably
this is the first time it's happened, you'd better
damn well be sure that they already know likely
charges that are on the other end of this and they
know exactly what they're looking for and what
they believe took place. But at the same time,
you've got to go through every document. You have
to see the legal implications of every document
that's there. Later, I'm going to tell you about
multiple Trump associates who believe there are
more documents or there are copies of documents
that Donald Trump still has stashed elsewhere. And
so it's not particularly realistic to think that
within ten weeks of getting the documents to begin
with, you're already going to be charging Donald
Trump. So while I completely disagree with the
idea of deliberately waiting to file charges until
after the election because Trump's not even on the
ballot, I totally disagree with that. If that is
what is going on, it seems more likely to me that
the timeline is going to extend beyond the first
week of November anyway. And I do believe we will
see an indictment, but I think it's going to come
later. Now, when we see the indictment, it will be
very interesting to see how Trump's lawyers react.
And we have a little bit of a preview of that.